hey guys Kirk Nichols from Boulder
Colorado here with one of the worst
starts in humankind history to a new
year what else could possibly go wrong
well this morning Tom Brady announced
that he will no longer be a New England
Patriot it's the end of an era and quite
frankly my mind is blown so well Tom
Brady following the footsteps of LeBron
James to LA my question to you is well
Tom Brady be the new king of LA
qinger stinging gang gang buzz-buzz
thanks fellas buzz buzz shot to Boulder
Colorado where your boy went to call it
Oh yep buffs huh Bob Central go uh the
sink okay hang out what is it the same
that's the bar we'd hang out low
ceilings tons of hoes oh I've been there
before
really on the hill there yeah you have
the pizza place right across the street
to get ice to run a bus company out
there with my buddy oh damn
from Boulder to Denver and they got a
full length medium to full and we got um
and uh we had some legal issues pop up
but yeah I was like party buses you know
you get people to get on there and party
drop him out there and drive him back
all them frat boys but people always
vomit and abortions everything on there
they were doing it all it's missing Jon
Benet style you know she got shut down
the one group I remember had a jonbenét
party the whole fraternity and sorority
out of Jon Benet they called it we're
going looking for it was set oh it was
JB and BJ
JB's and BJ's it was JonBenet's and blow
jobs was like kind of the other part and
what and what were the snacks was it
milk and pineapple that's a deep cut
it's a deep cut well I thought what they
the brother was eaten when every
allegedly killed her super deep I'm
gonna say this man I think that it's the
best thing for the Patriots to do I
think it's an ice cold move I don't
think that he's I think he's one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time but I
think it's his ability to take win them
a Super Bowl maybe is done I don't think
the relationship is you know it's over
he's there for 20 years be cool boss
he's there for 20 years he's also
getting a little older and he doesn't
have any help they have a good defense
but there's no offensive help you know
let him go
you think he's coming to LA thank you
he comes to LA charges he has offers
from LA charges in Tampa Bay but he has
a production studio out here he has a
house here in Bel Air
he's gonna move here so you have LA bran
and tombe both oldest [ __ ] but they're
here yeah yeah I don't know if I mean
it's like charges two years ago remember
they're they're the team they're the
[ __ ] team there's had a bad year last
year but you put Tom Brady on there the
boys gonna be bad
but also same conference is patching my
home's so it's gonna be tough for a man
to win anything yeah and your boy who's
your Denver boy new guy quarterback all
of them true lock drew Locke yeah do you
lock a rat now Kenny well there's video
of them sidelines just wrapping like
Soul Survivor I think it was Young Jeezy
song on the sideline yeah Young Jeezy
and calls himself a rap be on a dog
Young Jeezy went to Loyola bro I think
all of New Orleans it's probably them
well I don't know Lola gets pretty urban
Baltimore Chicago New Orleans to Loyola
Marymount hearing la soupe yeah it's
just white time and that's where James
[Laughter]
what is this guy asking about what is
his problem
it sounds like you guys are kinging him
being coming down it's coming down like
get your mind I don't think that it's
the best investment for the charges are
really don't I mean I don't think it's
bad but I have a quarterback right now
yeah but I think you just go with
somebody that's good and younger I mean
I don't know somebody young there's a
bunch of good quarterbacks coming out
yeah I think you're just gonna end up
with the team that loses in the first
round of the playoffs for the second
round of the house I'm not saying that
Tom Brady isn't great but do when Peyton
Manning came back for that last season
wherever that was Denver remember the
second one the second last ever you want
a Super Bowl in Denver yeah but that
last season he came back with there's
still want a Super Bowl it was old as
[ __ ] came out from the Colts we want a
Super Bowl yeah
Chargers need to fill seats - we won one
we won one Super all we lost it went to
two Super Bowls Peyton Manning that's a
good point
I bet Tom Brady plays three games and
it's a wrap I think there's no no way no
way Drago's on that joins the Chargers
midseason that veto or Antonio
now we're talking that'd be interesting
there you got weapons man two years ago
they were the [ __ ] squad people
forget
I'm sure Antonio Brown will do well in
LA yeah I don't know I just mean problem
I'm sure he'll see my son me what do you
guys think what's up what's happening to
me what is the aging Coulter think of
Tom Brady do you guys look at him as a
god like white people do or it is it but
does it matter she doesn't watch
football that chin likes the charges cuz
they used to have a Korean kicker
anymore yeah I mean they cut him they
did yeah Koo his name was Koo I forgot
the rest of his name was cool he does
like Chappell type [ __ ] before he kicks
it to no.1 Korean baby you forgot the
rest of his new that boy that man yeah
Dallas Cowboys and they have foo Yong ah
foo yung who lent you that new guy for
Atlanta the kicker qu yang oh I think
that's who I was thinking of he's the
guy that does all the flips and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Korean verbage Koo Yong Yong
Street legend bro he's badass he is
badass dude yeah I don't think he's
playing anymore so no yes yeah yes I
think Patriots huh
somebody picked him up from Georgia
Southern look at check this out boom
boom that's a ninja that plays football
everything it's all WWE Men everything
started in to WWE if this doesn't work
out he'd be the most lit Power Ranger
they got our fee what do you got what do
you think Chappelle I don't watch why so
there's a lot more black quarterbacks
now I know that much that's true Marv
Jackson MVP yeah one that's one right
Patrick mahomes half you're getting
worse on this one yeah I know right he's
just going down now this name a white
guy under drew brees great-great-grandpa
yeah who else I got this song Watson
Cam Newton Cam Newton Jameis Winston you
might be looking for a job too I don't
know what they're gonna do down there
yeah I don't know I mean it's definitely
a great move it to LA you know it seemed
like a
of players like the big-name start to
come over here because it's easy to do
endorsements all of that kind of stuff
like LeBron came here his whole
production stills out here I'll see you
know he wants to do good with the Lakers
but he has this whole squad out here
productions do all that stuff he's
making movies and [ __ ] yeah he do both
oh yeah Tom Brady the same way he has
his was it tb20 whatever the [ __ ] it is
12 t be 12 yeah his whole production
staff out here I'm just saying it's just
like what well if you do that out here
there's more opportunity for all that
you could start a show you could start a
studio get started all that kind of
stuff out here it seemed like more than
somewhere else you know for sure but so
yeah it's just like a lot of these guys
they come out to LA towards the end you
know smart move get paid to do your
business I think he's asking if who
would be new king of LA would it be
LeBron or would it be Tom Brady not that
he's coming to LA I think LeBron is
gonna win a championship this year with
the Lakers so yeah thank you
it's gonna be totally him and the other
best player in the league pretty much
man it's too much if they can be the
Greek freak
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]